i mean like i guess like what i want to
ask you guys is like i mean
we none of us have children right yeah
but like hypothetically right why'd you
say it like that
why don't you say it like right right
right right right not that we're up yeah
but like hypothetically
right like if you ever like get a kid
for example and you become the role of
the parent
and you walked in on your kid doing that
yeah like
how would you guys react like what would
you say join it
i don't know it's not it's not it's not
really to have a conversation there
you're like
sit down son it's like whoa what am i
doing but i'm sure some parents have
right
it's like oh my god i don't know like
what is even like as a parent what's the
correct answer
i probably tell them not to do it really
really because they're gonna do it
anyway
but you don't encourage them be like
watch as much porn as you want son
i feel like my dad said that why what
something similar he's just like because
like i i specifically
yeah you can get addicted to porn right
right but i specifically remember my dad
wasn't so much like disappointed in the
fact that i was like jacking off at all
because
it was the hentai it was the it was the
hunter it was the hentai
he was like i don't care that you're
jacking off that's [ __ ] like if you
have a penis and you're an adult that's
[ __ ] normal right
whatever you're eventually gonna get to
this point it could have been
anything else that you were jacking off
to i'd probably just you know walk out
and then the next time i see like my
child i'd probably just be like
we can just forget about it right and
then because that i i feel like the more
you talk about it
the more the more you put light on it
the worse that they're going to feel
just just make it
make it as casual as possible to be like
i feel so many parents you know end up
doing like the sit down son let's have a
talk
i feel that's the worst answer yeah you
know what i mean because like i feel
like there's nothing more i mean i never
got the talk
from my parents yeah but i feel if i
ever was in that position i'd be like
[ __ ] i want
did you ever ask your parents where
babies came from probably right they
probably just gave me some [ __ ]
answer yeah
any kid remember i still remember the
[ __ ] answer my mind
yes so i thought
that what literally what she said was
babies came out of the belly button
right
and thinking about this as and i don't i
think i'm
that's permanently scarred me because
when i see a belly button now
because as a kid as a kid i i had this
disgusting thought of
oh [ __ ] babies crawl out there
and now as a fully grown adult i still
see belly buttons i'm just like
ugh all right all i can think of is that
[ __ ] scene in ace ventura you know
when he's coming out of the [ __ ] like
rhino
that's all i can imagine it's like some
alien [ __ ]
like looking back i'd rather my mom had
just tell me
graphically where babies came from well
as as opposed to just telling me
yeah they crawl out the belly button
because i remember i remember the first
time
like there's there's two moments that
have scarred me for life one was that
and the second time was the first time i
saw the matrix
where matrix yeah the matrix there's a
scene
where have you guys seen the matrix yeah
i can't imagine a scene
okay so there's a way i think i know
which one there's a scene
as well yeah there's a scene where the
agents pin neo down
and then uh like a spidery shrimp
like emerges and then it crawls it it
crawls up his belly button yeah i saw
that
yeah and that [ __ ] me up so badly
because i'm just like
it okay i really forced it it reinforced
that it was possible for things to go
in or out of the belly button so i'm
just like protect this at all costs
i'm like yeah this is my vital one yeah
i thought it was
like some you know alien burst out sheer
wear she's like
you know i i i had a similar thing with
the with uh the mummy
you know when like the beetle is like
crawling underneath oh my god that was
the first time i
like physically was like i'm scared i
feel like yeah that magic scene i
blocked out
my mind yeah cause i remember being i
remember watching that like a 10 year
old and being disgusted
yeah god it's awful
but yeah i mean that's that's a tangent
right from porn yeah yeah i don't know
if i might cause my kid do it yeah i'd
probably be like well did you do it
efficiently
okay did you mean max's son how much
time did you spend
30 minutes you're in there for that's
way too long you cannot get in the habit
of doing that son